i hate the melon i hate watermelon i
hate pineapple
honeydew and
watermelon i hate it here we go let me
guess i haven't had the right one right
watermelon yeah i hate it water i hate
it
i hate it why
i'm gonna wager a guest because your
body is so brittle
and malnourished that the water content
of it makes bowels start moving and
gurgling
and you and you have to like you can't
handle it it's a fair guess
but you answered your question with your
mockery of me yes
it's water
it's delicious
i'll i'll go eat a [__] ice cube
and guess what i won't have to deal with
seeds
[Laughter]
have i just written a new bit about
watermelon yeah i think you did oh i
thought you were dipping into the taste
buds archive no no we just argued
watermelon and i lost terribly because
he i i'm also now appreciating how good
sal is
against you yeah uh cause you need that
you need that what are you talking about
hot day hot day you go home you have a
slice of watermelon your mom cuts you a
nice triangle of watermelon that holds
it together it's got good like
structural integrity that's exactly that
that's a really good impression that's a
good impression you'll i'm embarrassed
about what i took
that i lost with what do you mean
the fruit i lost to watermelon with i'm
embarrassed is it pineapple
raisins
for those of you not dying with laughter
the concept of taste buds is you're
arguing that raisins
are better than are better and here's
salad on raisins raisins or what the
crazy old lady with the lights off on
halloween if you go up to a door and and
you insist joe joe joe if you insist she
comes out and gives you a a dry crusted
box of raisins you brought up halloween
when you get the boxer races yes
you want to burn the person and you want
and you want to burn their house down
and if you do when you're caught they
say you were right they gave him they
gave him some sun
raisins can we clip it can we isolate it
can we clip it can we get it to sow yes
he's got to see this impression he
writes down the clips it's a perfect
impression of sal it's so good
it's perfect well i call them better
homes and i'm glad that we
his last name is end gardens
[Music]